et avec moi fabien paquette directeur
général responsable des vaccins chez
phrase du canada monsieur paquet bonsoir
bonsoir je vois parlons des doses
internet fois qu'on s'est parlé ça
parait il ya mille ans mais je fais pas
si longtemps on était dans un petit
creux de vague y avait des difficultés
les deux là elles arrivent en nombre
impressionnant de préparer un tableau
mois de mai deux millions de doses
semaine au canada que vous allez livrer
pour le québec c'est 455 milles et en
juin on monte encore à 2,4 millions de
doses semaine donc vous sans vous si on
a on a l'impression que maintenant ce
n'est plus une préoccupation pour vous
que d'acheminer un nombre de doses
important effectivement scherwey
maintenant mes temps on a mis en place
toutes les informations et les
précisions nécessaires pour pouvoir non
seulement avoir une livraison qui est
fait de façon continue et récurrente
mais aussi de s'assurer que si on est
dans une position de pouvoir augmenter
le volume comme on le fait au mois de
juin avec eux roulent à 2 2 millions 400
mille doses prévues pour chaque semaine
et qu'on continue de mettre de l'avant
ce genre de plat
l'objectif c'est bien sûr d'accélérer la
cadence de plus possible et d'immuniser
le plus possible de canadiens dans les
plus brefs délais
votre grand grand grand patron de chez
fraser a dit quelques semaines ça va
prendre une troisième d'euros sur mappy
peut-être une quatrième est ce que
d'abord où vous en êtes dans cette
analyse la pièce que c'est une saine
logique commerciale ou saine logique de
santé
en fait c'est certain que ça soit une
logique de santé parce que la décision
d'avoir besoin d'une dose de rappel va
être basé fondées sur des résultats
scientifiques des analyses techniques
qui vont démontrer le besoin ou non
d'avoir cette dose de rappel
actuellement les études sont mis en
place pour évaluer le contexte et voir
s'il ya besoin d'une dose rappelle
qu'elle serait l'intervalle et bien
évidemment on va attendre les résultats
de ces analyses de ces études là pour le
confirmer
et puis dans les prochains mois on
devrait avoir une réponse assez pour les
jeunes
12 à 15 ans dans votre cas mais 17 ans
le pour les écoles et qu'est ce que
votre votre vaccin c'est exactement le
même qu'on va donner aux jeunes
c'est juste que les études ont montré
qu'ils étaient efficaces autant efficace
chez les jeunes effectivement il ya une
étude qui a été complète aux états unis
pour le groupe des adolescents de 12 à
15 ans que démontrer un excellent profil
de sécurité mais également une
efficacité remarquable pour la traque c
est ce qui permet donc maintenant de
pouvoir avoir le mot location de notre
vaccin
enfin gmail aux insectes pour ce groupe
d'âge là qui a été octroyé hier par
santé canada donc une excellente
nouvelle qui permet de pouvoir accélérer
le rythme auprès d'une population qui
doit être vacciné
compte tenu de leurs risques autant pour
les conséquences pour humer mais
particulièrement partie sont des
vecteurs potentiels de transmission du
virus
bon alors effectivement avant la fin des
classes ça va plus vite que l'on croyait
vous l'avez dit c'est une bonne nouvelle
par ailleurs vous voyez comme moi la
pression internationale qui monte pour
que vous et les autres pharmaceutiques
suce pas y est temporairement vaut
brevet de sorte qu'on pourrait produire
sur la planète l'afrique du sud ailleurs
beaucoup plus de quantité de vaccins
pour desservir les pays qui en ont moins
et locke key est ce que fritzl est prêt
à écouter ces demandes
écoutez on comprend que c'est un jeu qui
est extrêmement important et vous
réalisez que un jeu comme l'ensemble des
compagnies pharmaceutiques veut
favoriser l'utilisation et le
déploiement d'un maximum de vaccins
partout sur la planète
d'ailleurs les enfants qu'on est déployé
pour augmenter nos capacités de
production
on parlait de 2.1 millions de doses
qu'on a monté à 2.5 milliards de doses
cette année on parle de plus de trois
milliards de doses année prochaine
dénonce cette volonté de pouvoir offrir
le maximum d'un vaccin
l'ensemble est arrivé mais on croit que
la levée des brevets des meilleurs
moyens on pense que la meilleure façon
de pouvoir offrir davantage de vaccins
à l'ensemble de la planète c'est de
pouvoir faciliter davantage la
production où ça fonctionne bien donc
par exemple nos usines et de s'assurer
que l'expertisé a été mise en place
continue de pouvoir favoriser une
accélération la production et du
développement de l'axé mais je lisais
que l'argumentaire de feu c'est de dire
la recette est tellement compliqué que
même si on lève les brevets l'oeil
ailleurs il serait pas capable de faire
ce que c'est un peu ça vous dit
effectivement parce que c'est une chose
est d'avoir les connaissances et
expertises les capacités production
d'avoir le matériel d'avoir les russes
qui s'appelle les produits nécessaires à
la fabrication du produit
tous ces éléments font en sorte que le
niveau de complexité
on n'est pas certain que ça devrait
accélérer la cadence face à va accélérer
le rythme de faire cette façon là on
n'est plus dans un contexte où avec
l'expérience qu'on a avec les matières
premières qu on a
et toute la facilité de produire il a
plus de pouvoir offrir ok mais offrir
davantage de vaccins en terminant
monsieur paquet est ce que ça veut dire
qu'on l'a fait pour le vih à l'époque
est ce que ça veut dire couper les prix
beaucoup pour les certains marchés
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à négocier
parce que là quand je dise la pression
monte
l'organisation mondiale du commerce
monsieur ben haydn au canada on dit qu
on suit ça monsieur macron qui est
d'accord avec ça donc vous senti la
pression internationale fin aux yeux et
vous faites beaucoup d'argent ce moment
c'est quoi votre réponse alors dit on
veut pas jouer aux cartes là en avez
vous une autre à jouer mais cela me suis
moi je pense qu'on a démontré de notre
intérieur entre autres avec
l'organisation kovacs c'est pouvoir
fournir les vaccins à ces pays là va
devoir le développement à un prix tout à
fait raisonnables qui correspond à la
capacité de pouvoir se l'offrir et je
vous dirais qu'on a des différences
d'échelle de prix à travers le monde
pour justement répondre à cette
situation je peux vous garantir que pour
ces pays en voie de développement
mais les prix sont appropriés pour leurs
conditions leur capacité de pays
alors oui on veut continuer d'offrir ce
genre de partenariat et faire en sorte
qu'on puisse davantage y mettre à la
disposition des doses mais la levée
temporaire des brevets vous étiez pas
c'est une fausse bonne idée dit vous
c'était la meilleure au premier abord
mais c'est pas la meilleure façon pour
ce duo parce que il ya d'autres façon à
arriver au même objectif est d'offrir
davantage de vaccins aux gens qui en ont
besoin
enfin se reparler tous à fabien paquette
directeur général responsable des
vaccins j'ai fait ce jeu canada merci
nous avons parlé ce seront mes reins
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
[Musique]